following days of riots in Senegal the
police say they are here to protect the
people but in this video widely shared
on social media the security forces are
seen using an eight-year-old boy as a
human shield to stop protesters from
attacking them a breach of Article 15 of
the UN convention on the rights of the
child
when demonstrator shouts stop guys don't
throw any rocks look the boy is scared
then the protesters throw insults to the
police
during a press conference we asked the
interior Minister about this video
in Senegal we cannot accuse Security
forces of using children as human
Shields what if police were in fact
saving and protecting the children there
is a lot of manipulation online
we spoke to the family of the young boy
they say they have received threats and
intimidation from authorities and are
now afraid to speak out
Riot broke out Nationwide after
oppositionko was sentenced to two years
in jail last Thursday his supporters say
the verdict is politically motivated to
eliminate sunko ahead of the
presidential election of February 2024.
demonstrators have looted supermarkets
Banks and people's homes the government
has been severely restricting access to
the internet shutting it down completely
in certain neighborhoods authorities say
it's to stop illegal Gatherings and
protests and prevent fake news
circulating independent journalist
Sports Hotel calls it an e-curfew
curtailing freedom of speech after
posting critical posts there were
attempts to restrict her Twitter account
people understand the power of social
media
covering this much but local media is
not covering much because they may be a
threat as well the riots have now
subsided the government tactics seem to
be working in keeping people off the
streets but despite the internet
restrictions the protest movement is
moving online to express dissent and
fuel anger
Nicholas Hawk Al Jazeera Dakar